generous benefaction from the late
professor David Siegel and Professor
Beatrice Siegel the leader of American
Medicine in the program today is Matthew
Walker
formerly professor of surgery and
currently promised for internal affairs
at maharry Medical College Nashville
Tennessee
Professor Walker is interviewed by Louis
J Bernard who succeeded him as chairman
of the department of surgery at Mahari
repeatedly say over and over again
that uh you were born in waterproof
Louisiana and we hear you probably talk
about this as your hometown
how long were you there
Argent waterproof about three or four
years uh I was born there and of course
after a while my mother and father moved
to New Orleans for two reasons one was
for better economic situation another
was to allow me to have a better
education and then I moved to New
Orleans you know I mean I've fallen in
three or four years the first three or
four years of your life I am I'm a
little surprised because I happen to
know from my personal experience that
every time he had the opportunity to
present you back down there again what
what was so attractive about it what
takes you back there well when I was in
grade school when I was in high school
in the summertime when I was younger I
would go to the country that's out to
waterproof and there I would swim help
to plow
fish hunt
from time to time and that's why I'll
usually go back there now whenever I
would get a chance and even bring my
residents back there
what uh you got your grade school
education I got my grade school
education in New Orleans apart I started
New Orleans in kindergarten we used to
pay a dime a week a museum in
kindergarten then I went to Tom lefon
and there was a public school in New
Orleans and of course after Public
Schools I went to high school in New
Orleans at a private high school private
Academy Roger choose a private high
school after I haven't been in public
school for six seven or eight years well
my parents thought that I would get a
better better education in the private
school this was uh Gilbert Academy which
was a part of New Orleans University and
was a demonstration school and then you
went right on into New Orleans
University
what kind of education would you
consider you received during these years
was this the classical kind of education
was
uh was it a practice at that point in
time to have two kinds of uh Pathways
for students one intended to take them
into college and into professions and
another into the trades
I was just the usual classical education
what kinds of things the usual classical
classical education we the foundations
of Latin French and of course the basic
sciences and that type of thing how much
Latin did you get I had three years of
Latin and four years of French two years
of French in high school and two years
of French in college my friend sounds
great what'd you do with that Latin
basis of a lot of languages and when I
first got to medical school in those
days we were prescriptions in Latin and
came and handed in I see I see and uh
do you have any special Recollections of
some of the people
who taught you in those years in those
high school years and those college
Years whereas in the high school years I
remember very definitely
um a little later from
choose white because a lot of news came
down to New Orleans University to teach
and she taught us mathematics her name
was the Sweden
and she made it mathematics seemed so
simple so beautiful and then I recall
another Miss Parker who is the registrar
and fellas didn't have much money in
those days and I remember very
definitely that one fellow had four
grandmothers to die because anytime
somebody dies they forgive you for your
tuition okay next time and so on but it
was that type of thing then a reverend S
C Walker who eventually married I
married my wife and me and uh he was
teaching us Bible and public speaking
um
when did you decide that you were
interested in medicine what point along
the way actually it was when I was in
grade school by eighth grade when we
were studying hygiene
and what had genius appealed to me and I
thought that the closest I could get to
really dealing with hygiene was to be a
physician was that the only choice did
you consider anything else oh yes but
this Reverend Walker without us Bible
wanted me to go in there Ministry it's
been a great preacher well maybe so but
I finally didn't go out
okay and uh throughout the years of high
school and years in college this
remained pretty firm right so you really
had entered college with the idea that
you'd be going on in medicine and not
only that of course all my college
preparation was taught in this what
kinds of things did you take what what
major at that point New Orleans was
known New Orleans University was known
for a number of Sciences and so then we
took uh histology embryology anatomy and
all the bodies and bacterialis in the
total uh course in biology who dissected
the cat and even made a hundred slides I
remember very definitely
good now
in choosing medicine
you feel that you could articulate for
me what your feelings were other than
the fact that hygiene was interesting
that made you decide to
run a medicine as a career one of that
grew old of course I began to realize
that medicine first would give a lot of
service to people
the next thing the idea of getting
people well who was sick
that simple thing appeal to me and of
course as I went further and further I
realized how important that whole idea
was I didn't choose my hiring as a place
to cut your medical school education
well
I shared my hair first because
there was
there were two schools around there that
is Tulane and LSU
but nurse days is Unthinkable for a
black to enter a white Medical School
how do you feel about that Paul didn't
bother me at all it was the order of the
day and I just said well one of these
days to learn some sense and so I went
on to my area because my family
physician was from mayor that was Dr
Bowles then of course we had another
person Charles Brown Charles Brown
that's right he has a son who finished
medicine also and another Dr Alexander
came to town and of course those two
impressed me to come to mahara well I
happen to know that you delayed a year
going into medical school from coming
out of college did you have a problem
getting admitted no the question was I
had a friend
who we studied together in college and
actually what we did about five of us we
should put up 25 cents a piece for
examinations and the one who make the
highest Mark will get the but and this
boy Beacon was my strongest competitor
didn't have money quite together and so
I agreed to stay out of the year for him
so we could be classmates at mahara but
he died in the meantime so I came home
by myself that sounds pretty interesting
as a reason for delaying
I have a pleasure listen to medical
school students pretty frequently
I haven't told me the problems and what
an ordeal Medical School is
how do you feel about being a medical
student
well no actually it was a lot of fun
uh the first thing I remember that made
a difference to me was I realized that
there was a difference in medical school
in college
because I had all those basic Sciences
in college and histology I had
embryology
and uh I just wouldn't read them that's
all but no point I knew enough about
them and I woke up one day and had
examination with 20 on the on the paper
when I had to change my whole way of
living and so I'll have to be sure to
report that to some of your old students
saying you did make a 22. okay
uh who are some of your teachers then
available yes in the basic science the
man who gave me the 20 was Dr Hernandez
who is an excellent he
teaches histology was
a psychiatrist and neurologist he
happened in the pharmacist and also an
attorney and so he was well prepared
tragically already right already that's
right they might do wrong it was a very
excellent teacher and Dr West in
chemistry those are the ones I remember
very definitely and uh uh the basic
sciences and the clinical Sciences of
course Dr Hale Dr MacMillan who was
surgeons and then there was a man Dr
Walt Reed we call him War Reed it was
Walter Reed but he was really tall he
taught what was then known as
Therapeutics and pharmacology and he was
classical well what do you mean it was
classical but I mean he he week in Latin
healing what was former what was proper
who was improper any new ethics we asked
to face man really let me know the
importance of real ethics in a medical
student and one early because when I
finished medical school I had agreed to
stay at my hair then the lady for whom I
worked in New Orleans was a Catholic and
she had arranged for me to go to St
Louis with the Catholic school there uh
to intern and so Dr Lee Thomas said
listen you give me a word he had my hair
and I'm okay if you don't have a one
patient in my heart and have 100
patients there you won't be with
anything if you break your word so you
have to stay here
and so I'll stay with my hair
now as you came out of my Harry you uh
did an internship
at what point on the line along the line
did you make a decision that uh surgery
was the thing of when I was a sophomore
when I decided to be said we're not
decide on surgery it appears to me that
the surgery I've got people well who've
been in medicine
three times a day before meals but the
surgery just cut it out when the patient
did all right so that's why I went to
church I hope not too many of your
medical friends
who will heal it but uh
are you saying to me that you felt that
uh you were more active participant than
what happened to the patient right and I
could control it better as an individual
you see rather than women but of course
the medical people with all due respect
to them have just as definite ideas
about being viewed well as a surgeon
yeah it does I do but to me surgery was
the thing
now realizing that Mahari in 1934
did not have a structured Residency
program I was wondering if you'd uh
describe for me how you proceeded to get
this training
well um the first thing the president
and hail and Mac Miller all of one of
them instead my hair for the complete
train who the hell in MacMillan well Dr
Hill was the head of central at that
time and Dr McMinn was the head of
genocology and uh I was working with
both of them and so I agreed to stay and
so
in general surgery Dr Hill was my
teacher in gene ecology Dr MacMillan was
my teacher and uh we went on and on year
one two three I think I was the first
resident had stayed there three years
how many residents did you have you
never won I was the only resident I see
and when I was at one resident on Serbia
one resident on medicine the resident on
surgery covered general surgery
Gynecology obstetrics ear nose and
throat orthopedic and neurology because
of everything and of course in those
days the resume was teaching everything
and so they gave me a terrifically broad
experience
so really it was receptive pretty right
uh what do you think about this as a
technique for training people I think
it's all right if that's the best you
have but that was a form of training you
know in the older days and of course the
former residency was developed and after
I finally said of course they gave me a
general education board Fellowship to go
and study on the doctor every house who
had started off at heel and went to
Columbia and came to Harvard and I was
there with him for a year and that's
then of course I went to various places
went to Harvard they used to go without
the Oliver cope
I have a summer for two weeks or to a
month Mayo Clinic May Clinic as well as
places so first I wanted to know what
was in the mainstream of surgery because
I decided to develop a surgical training
program next I want to be sure to know
what's going on and then of course
sergey's operating I want to see all
those operations I hadn't seen and I was
able to do all that
we're the people who who are advising
you in this time period
we're doing the earlier days Dr Hale Dr
Mac Miller
when I was being trained advisement
together with Dr Turner who Dr Turner
was a man who had come from the
Rockefeller Foundation at Bennett Beirut
there as a rock fellow man in that
University and then he came to Manhattan
American University in Maryland American
University when it came to Harris uh
head of internal medicine
of course he became president he was
white but he was a very fine man and he
really brought the scientific medicine
to mahara and he got interested in me
somehow and began to advise him straight
on through
that's why he's the one upon me having
the problem of surgery when Dr Hill died
in 1944.
what point in time did you consider
yourself no longer training but your
expression the full-grown surgeon
well it was a long time before I
considered myself a full-grown surgery
in the first I wasn't prepared I wasn't
ready to begin a department Dr Hill just
had had him die and I was there and it
made me in
but after I'd run him for about a year
or two I finally decided I could do all
right
what uh what happened to to bring you to
feel this way well uh there were a
number of cases that came in I remember
two in particular like one was a big
arterial venus aneurysm in the groin and
uh which I never seen anybody do and I
picked him up in South Carolina I got
the longest Clinic the group from
Harvard I turned it down the group from
San Luis I turned him down I told him
the center of the next we're not doing
them so you demonstrate him with all the
signs and symptoms and everything there
for the clinic and they send them to
Nashville and in those days uh Royals
are from stabborn gunshot
it was classical and all the Brewer and
everything and so Dr Bonner Brooks was
in who was at head of surgery at
Vanderbilt was individual who was doing
that type of thing in this area and Dr
Elkin and Georgia Atlanta and then of
course down in New Orleans I had a group
and so the side of Atlanta broke was
during the war about doing this he said
okay send them over to Vanderbilt
and so Dr John said what do you say
about I said no I won't send him over to
Vanderbilt if he come over here and do
it it's all right
because all my students are still uh
couldn't go over there but as soon as
the staff must see it at that time I
hadn't developed a security code every
leader the one so he said when was top
man that did was on it and look at it
for about 15-20 minutes and get a
drawing he ended up staying there three
hours
and while I sweat over the case and of
course case was finishing every day when
Black Books would call the best I had to
turn out I was the man he said he's
doing fine man went on back to South
Carolina started drinking licking the
same Tavern and start all over again
but since then I consider myself
mentioned in the war years reminds me
that uh
but a very auspicious event to take
place on your 35th birthday that was
Pearl Harbor
as a Jew I don't know anything about
your military
well uh in those days they were head
what do you call Satan men were frozen
in medical schools in order to teach
medical students to provide Physicians
for the law and I wanted to go to a war
not because I was hanging with anybody
but I wanted to go to the Walmart to get
some experience in more surgery when I
was one of the ones who was frozen to
teach and I stayed in my house to teach
so we were there that time period when
you would
tell me I'm not quite 90 day wonders as
it did for for the Infantry in the
auditory and stuff but you're turning
out something even of a wonder why
you're taking kids two years out of
college and putting them through uh 28
months of
of a medical school experience and
giving them medical degrees yes that was
a hectic time for the tissues because
usually the teachers kind of taking
these kind of doctors you think you were
turning out well I think they did all
right actually I really haven't done no
scientific study to see just how they
compare with other doctors but generally
they've been just as good uh do you
think that's the way to go you know it
would be maybe a little cheaper to do it
that way
a little faster
I think probably the medical profession
can't stand that because in this day of
specialization
a friend doesn't need all the stuff that
we give them it's too much it could be
condensed it could give them a call of
the education and then let them spend
the extra years any particular specialty
that they would want nothing to be just
as good I don't think it would be as
broad but it might not be necessary to
be as wrong if you're going to work on
our eye why learn all that stuff about
it too
okay we might get some arguments on that
so that uh
in 1944 10 years out of medical school
you found yourself chairman of a
department of surgery and but you must
have had some idea of where you wanted
to go at that point oh yes the first
thing I did was sat on and wrote out the
progress and Development Department
surgery for the next 20 years which
included the training of residences uh
residences taking that board
uh training of men and very specials to
bring back to help the department of
surgery to make a complete department
and also include visiting and making
friends in contact with the leading
surgeons throughout the country
none of us playing the most interesting
thing is I look back on it now was that
at the end of 20 years the salary for
the professional problem was ten
thousand dollars now I've seen that I
thought that was pretty interesting
I asked a chairman of a department after
going through a um a variety of things
in terms of your exposure in terms of
your training you're having a problem
being admitted to examination by the
American Board of surgery or to the
surgical societies
now there was no problem to the American
Board of central because with uh the
training that I had
trained with Dr house I was admitted and
of course it so happened that I'd done
all those basic sentences I've done
three years of anatomy three years of
pathology three years of physiology
three years of bacterial energy while I
was growing all this process development
and I was pretty well grounded in basic
Sciences together with extensive reading
and when the board was given to John
Hopkins and Hawkins wrote Dr Tony I made
one of the two highest marks that John
Hopkins at the time and so there was no
problem about the board but the problem
was in these American College of
Surgeons and those type of organizations
because at that time there was the one
black man in the American College of
savings and he was in New York and I
understand he had just got in there
because he was one of the ones who come
from Harvard and took them all together
and so uh I just didn't even apply for
it I'm saying I appreciate that one day
Doctor Laura Brooks and Vanderbilt he
and I had developed a good relationship
then after uh made DeSean on the board
and after alternative aneurysm when he
was just almost a father to me
everything at Vanderbilt all decisions
at Vanderbilt were on my staff
you know that someone who's neurosurgeon
pear tree and mutant Warner staff
Daniels I know even billock was on the
staff when he was there um chest surgery
and we didn't have any staff I was the
only surgeon there and so I had to get
them and they were willing to come and
hurry and having the money so they came
for nothing except some people who
somebody who came regularly every week I
paid him a noble sum of 50 a month that
was just a total I have to know you
still pay some of them just 50 bucks
right right so you just hit a department
now that's your word to change that but
we didn't have the money in those days
right now
so you suddenly found yourself with a
department to build with a program that
you wanted to mount
I wonder if you would tell me something
about exactly how you went about doing
this thing well the first thing I had to
find out what was going on in the
mainstream as I indicated the only way
to find that out there was no travel
funds in those days no developmental
funds so I took my own money and every
summer went to these various places
Harvard Yale Michigan Minnesota and so
on and and made contact with the leaders
Etc at the time this is for two reasons
first to learn what was going on inside
around these places so I could map my
program accordingly second to make these
friendships so I could have a basis a
place for sending them in before the
training
now seems to me if you're talking this
way you had some particular idea where
you wanted to go
where those ideas came from
remember the most important thing to me
was the fact that when I became part of
the head of department of surgery and Dr
Haley died they had no surgeons on the
market they couldn't buy no matter how
much money they had it just so happened
that I was around and of course it paid
some attention to surgery and I suppose
they wanted to consider five or six men
they wanted five or six men in the
country the train would be ahead of an
apartment
and so I decided then to train so many
men and training well that anytime a man
is wanted in surgery there'd be so many
selective Builders I have no problem the
next I decided to train these men so I
had to have the best possible black men
to compete favorably anywhere in the
country and anywhere in the world and
that's what I set out to do because it
was needed it went out on the market and
the only thing to do is develop them
at the time you took over from Dr Hale
how many residents did you have I had
one resident that was a Dr crop
came back to talk was the residents came
along like I was coming along and of
course he was like one year after that
thing on that but my first uh resident
before he was Dr period
and everybody he was a full-time
resident and then of course in those
days I was head of genocology also when
I had a resident in Gynecology which
meant two running young surgery one in
general College
the general College resident would have
to do some safety in order to learn how
to sew up a gut if he put a hole in it
the surgical resident rotated through
Junior College in order to do it and a
general College resident could not be
trained in general college alone he had
to also be an obstetric but my secretary
had to go under Dr James and that type
of thing
and so this is the way it started the
next one was uh that's again so you see
answer here Atlanta talking about Dr
Yancey how did you um
find yourself
in terms of means of private clinical
material for
for getting a Residency program really
moving what I soon realized that uh in
medicine 10 people could listen at one
heart
but in surgery when you cut out One
appendix you two of that patient had to
get some more patience somewhere else
and so the mountain bike situation
opened up accurate it was uh the well
maybe in the Mumbai situation well there
was a group in Mount Bayou known as The
Mysterious International order of 12 the
knights and Daughters of the table and
that was then headed by Sir PM Smith he
was a fan of the Keller Miller Smith
here in Nashville and uh it came to me
by running this hospital and I Dr Hayden
had just died and I was working there
oh no
I was
debating there's nothing not to leave
and so of course not to turn it all up
and told me it was no one thing about
leaving
and so I finally told him and I sent him
three or four names
to the good game so they selected one
and then after then after three years
they had Party friend sort of came back
to me again when it came back to me
again I told him that I still couldn't
kill myself but I have a residence
attorney program that I could surprise
them in and run the surgery in the
hospital and that's where it began in my
own bank and I was going to mount Bayou
we had three objectives or four
objectives one was that we wanted to
give a Better Health Care delivery to
the people in the area second I wanted a
place for my more advancement and
surgery third we wanted to teach them
about Community Health
preventive medicine that type of thing
and we also wanted to offer a place for
the black doctors in the area to learn
how to go in the hospital because at
that time black doctors had no hospital
to go into kind of pulling fellow can
finish nursing 10 20 years previously
didn't want to ride on my child because
it's just one permitted and so that
offered a place for them to go we'd hold
conferences and seminars and that
service and doctors in the area who was
the first marriage the first man I sat
down there was 80th the next man I sat
down was the answer and so on down the
line is that the answer why I did was
that after one finishes in our program
for at least a year and of course then
of course he would go around as a
sophomore
and once you come from the program and
from dreams program are you from Chicago
and Drew and I were running
simultaneously in apartments
I never know about some other things
that you're apparently will concerned
and doing at that point in time
in 1948 you had the first uh what's it
hell McMillan lecture I think Dr houses
it was Dr House Dr Daley was the first
lecture
tell me about that and why'd you do that
well Dr Hill and Dr McMillan we were
very notable Pioneer in Sergeants
they've done a great job for surgery and
for medicine and for Obstetricians and
ecology in Nashville so I thought that
it was sitting improper to honor them
and to keep their memory alive by having
the most outstanding men in surgery at
the time to come give a lecture every
year and that's when we started and with
the context that I had made already by
going about
throughout the country I didn't have any
difficulty getting the leading surgeons
at the time to give these lectures are
those still running when you're still
running this is about the the 20th isn't
it yeah I think so 28 uh 1948 yeah uh
election uh we were doing some other
kinds of things too at that time I know
your ship hurry up your ship Bennett you
tried to ship Kane and oh yes that was
interesting now uh as I told you when I
started I was the only man in the
problem and I soon realized that I
couldn't
New Orleans we've been working all of
the areas I work from there the guy get
hit in the head and then
yeah right hand surgery and everything I
could get my hands on but I realized I
couldn't last and so then I decided to
develop uh more men to come back and
teach now it still happened that I was
fast enough to attract good men to the
program and of course given the maximum
amount of training with emphasis on
Excellence emphasis on really paying
attention to the patient whatever's on
reading extensively
emphasis on going to basic Sciences
since I went to all those basic Sciences
they had to go also because I thought
that was a good basis for Saturday and
of course research we had only residents
trying to do research but I finally
found out that all of them were not
interested but those who were interested
in on with the research now we kept that
up and then I finally decided to send
them off to this various places man who
and when I started off I just tell John
you go here
and Henry you go here but when it I
think I started broke me up with that
because that's something to Harlem and
with Dr Francis Moore now I thought
anybody would go there I would want it
but anyway he's saying he wanted to go
to Memorial but I said Frank Perry
Memorial and uh I used to have 30
telephone bill and make minute stay
there but he did well there he uh he
knows the expensive mobiles had
applications remember you tell me the
difficulty of accepting a man and uh the
competition and how they would come
there down on probation for six weeks
Jacqueline and Franklin don't worry
about a man that I send him he worried
about his own men because they'll be
able to compete well with anybody two
weeks after Bennett Rosanna had been a
teaching and so there was no probation
at all and he delivered the
research paper from the Department of
surgery on 11 oxygen Hebrew steroids at
the American college decision
fundamental Forum which means that he
didn't well and Frank Perry did the same
thing at the memorial and so on good
uh we pray for this
well when I used to do that was the long
story because in addition to getting the
place how to get them the money
and the general education board the
Rockefeller foundation and managed to go
out to see Dr Lampard and all that type
of thing about getting money from and to
get the money from also and was able to
do it that way
you know I had to do was travel made to
contacts got in the position and all
these men uh to round it out
Dr Randall then of course
they retired on the doctor Miller High
and heart surgery
billiona not to stand at that time and
all the feelings then later down at
Memorial that is uh yeah because they
had so many problems then of course uh
Dr Charles Brown at Harvard with Dr
sweet and so on and all those are back
now and first when I sent him a lot of
them didn't come back
when I decided to start selling the way
I just give me the best I could there
here at mahara and I didn't know him
anymore and so I did that for about two
years that I plan I stopped I decided
then train so darned many of them to the
law of overflow we'll make something to
run up and come back to my house when I
signed to develop a program how does
that work to your satisfaction quite
well but you said one of those
individuals and he was in an apartment
now so it's a good deal
do you consider your major contributions
to medicine and medical science one of
the things that you if someone had to uh
develop a deliver eulogy and said these
are the things
that really made Matthew Walker's Life
in Korea with it
what would you say they were I think the
most important thing as I said was my
training of men
uh it might have come from the the
natural feeling of reproducing one's
kind
that I think it's more than that it's
the fact that to me in the country was
for the training of men particularly
black men and I decided to vote my life
to turn them in because I'm only one
person but if I Train 50 100 men I have
that many men to deliver good health
care in the world
another thing that enters me was the
question of uh the number of Health Care
to the ghetto the living room Health
Care to rural areas and that's where
Mount Bayou came in and instead I
started out my own by you for the reason
I indicated but found out the question
grew when we got interested in the whole
problem of delivery of Health Care and
uh the outreach program at mahara now
with the mission at Meharry now that is
empathy for the disadvantaged
partnership with the community accident
uh academic Excellence was started as
the beginning with the rent over a
million dollars for real Health Center
in my body and a comprehensive urban
center here in Nashville what's the name
of the one in Nashville do you want
somehow to recount enough the name of
the Matthew Walker Health Center okay
all right so you were saying that uh
the two things that you've told me about
have been this matter training man and
what I heard coming through to me you
were talking about postgraduate training
right and you're talking about
Healthcare delivery and attempting to
affect the whole system right one thing
that I know about you haven't mentioned
to me is it
remember many times you told me when
that student flunks it's my fault oh yes
that took a long time to get over to my
staff all these men who I've seen
actually I happen to be chairman of
curriculum committee at the same time
and I had definite philosophies about
how to teach and uh the first place I
was against all those lectures because I
didn't think much of anything but
Showmanship for the lecturer I thought a
student could learn better by being
guided and directed to go read himself
and then come back and teach you and uh
I thought that the teacher was
responsible for the students success or
failure and I would tell my man all the
time that if a student failed the
teacher also failed because it's up to
the teacher to teach the student in such
a way or provide an atmosphere of
learning that was so important to the
students tonight what do you say about
surgical residents now uh surgical
residents uh
I said about surgical resonance you
cannot cause rotten wood
so there's no point in selecting a man
who's no good because of the selected
man who's no good he's riding wood he's
gonna be riding wood if you're taking 12
years and so I selected men who were
good frankly okay that's uh
that's where those residents came from
from that pool of students huh right
right right right right so some of them
some residents and some individuals just
paid more attention to Medicine matters
but the most important thing is that
we're willing to work because they had
we couldn't be a they have to have
some brains uh but I remember Dr Hill
used to tell us to ask Addison's Edison
you're a genius you you learn all these
things what was your success what is the
reason for you being a genius Edison
said Jesus is a man who works and works
and weeks and weeks now a good resident
is a man who works and works and works
and works is that a part of medical
students too
here but of course
we're a resident you see because a lot
of considering my idea My Philosophy is
Salvage and you should do everything we
can to salvage this medical student even
giving them remedial work and all that
type of thing because we want to
increase the number of medical
physician
all right so you've been very much
concerned about this business of
training medical students you've been
very much concerned about training
surgeons now this causes me to raise a
very specific issue with you
and I'm sure that many of us these days
were given thought to this
I've seen a good deal of material coming
out from the AMA from American College
of sessions which would say that maybe
you're saturated with surgeons maybe you
have too many surgeons why are you
talking about the train surgeons or
having a continuing interest over so
long in training surgery
might apply to white but I don't think
they're apply to blacks
the first thing we don't have too many
black surgery we don't have enough of
course not only the big thing in that is
distributions now how we're going to
distribute these surgeons why an implant
to the places where they're needed is a
problem to be solved the only idea about
how to do that
well some of the South American
countries have uh not allowed them to to
get their degrees and that type of thing
I want them to spend so much time in the
rules and the face of the ghetto you can
withhold their filing certificates until
they spend so much land they're not
going to be bad there are rumors to the
effect you know that uh
a federal government will will draw all
support for medical schools and you will
then have to pay from the nub you know
the full cost of the experience which
would then mean lots of people will be
borrowing money if they elected to to go
to medical school do you think this
might be a technique right right and
they could forgive them all if they
spend so many years in the ghetto so
many years in a row that would be a good
idea
how do you feel about the menu turned
out over there this 30th time period
that you chair that uh that department
well as we started uh what these men are
doing we found out first in almost every
Community repriment among the top men in
scientific surgery in the community
to my surprise I found out that a number
of those men have gone into uh Women's
Health Delivery Systems uh surgeon
they've been ahead of Comprehensive
Health Clinics and that type of thing I
don't know whether it's the fact of a
surgeon want to get things done people
tell them they're aggressive that way
you know they just just got to do things
that that could be in and of course it's
amazing and really gratifying to see the
large number of fellows whom have
trained who own the faculties of medical
schools and they're keeping up there who
still doing research who's still
studying who's still going to meeting
because actually as you know I started
off taking them to the American College
of surgery before I was a member of the
college and in those days we had no
grants we had no money and what we did
was put I put them in my car and a bunch
of us went together stayed at the YMCA
because we didn't have much money we
were all enjoying ourselves we had a
grand time because the whole question of
the development of surgery in our
program that it was a family of yeah it
was a family affair no big you and Lila
and that type of thing everybody was
working to First do the best job
possible second to produce in a way that
they can compete further with residents
from any school in the world and third
in order to be able to be the best type
of serving after you finish and make the
best possible showing on the American
Board of surgery have you ever heard of
an organization called Matthew Walker
surgical Club yes I have the photos are
very nice and kind yeah they saw him at
around about 1958 1958 and at that time
I trained 67 sessions and at the moments
about 100 that have come into my
uh tutelage now they have a very great
time I never will forget that we usually
have two rooms one room to drink liquor
and 10 lines another room to sit down
and eat and tell lies and such a line
telling of those meetings
yeah that's usually hell at the time of
the uh
meetings that shift gears a little bit
what are some of your pet ideas some of
the things that uh
throughout your lifetime has really
moved you that uh
things are important to you and I'm not
talking about just medicine
or surgery
if I'm talking about you as an
individual well I think
it's difficult to tell but one of the
things was having uh impress and
intrigued with the whole process of
information and phenomenal information
in a matter of surgical development and
uh
when I started out the house I had one
phase of information that was wound
healing and then of course when
penicillin first came out
we did some research in the whole
question of penicillin and peritonitis
and I never forget in those days unlike
now we paid the individuals nothing
because our team was component most of
our students and I remember Dr who's not
being was head of this group and their
students had it so well
then they could produce pregnant on his
mind turn off the penis and giving the
patient in the audience giving the
patient the dog rather Castro and of
course they could predict just about how
long the dog would live and one of the
things that we enjoyed about that is we
had the only pure culture of couples in
the whole hospital at the time and the
whole uh laboratory and so that whole
process of information in penicillin
matter an incident last time to follow
the first man we did Paschal every day
he's now working in a supervisor in
Detroit
another thing that interests me
intrigued me is the delivery of Health
Care Comprehensive Health Care our
concerned for an individual who does not
have good health care our concerned not
to just wait till he comes out of office
as a episodic care but to go out and
look for him and bring him in and give
him preventive care and take care of him
properly and as a human being talking
about that kind of stuff well I think it
said you to be a surgeon he's got to be
interested in human beings not just the
surgery that individual and a total
individual you must
you know uh recently you've been on my
back about something that I I've got to
ask you about
for what is it for about two years now
this committee on death and dying oh yes
I have had a lot of fun uh
trying to get my concept of three people
should be redeveloped and we changed
over two years just about everything
from uh early introduced deduction of
the patients to the student integration
of medicine all that type of thing but
death and dime is the latest kick I had
really because people don't know how to
die and doctors will go out when they
have people who die and then we can go
back to Rome used to say and of all his
readings in all his education and all
his travel one thing is not only to be
constant that the mortality of the human
race is 100 so it will be best for me
this is to teach these medical students
how to die themselves and also teach
them how to face death with their
patients
foreign
ministers lawyers and that type of thing
forming the nucleus of the committee and
teaching in the integrated fashion so
that we would recognize that death is a
natural phenomenon and I guess you're
not a cause anybody to go to pieces but
rather would do everything first to
prevent death but one death once death
occurs we shouldn't adjust because the
living must continue to go on
you've seen a lot of changes in medicine
over the years
the medical student
the same as the medical student
mentoring Mahari in 1944.
now when I talked to the old student
they swear that they're better than the
students today
but not that can't be sold
maybe in some instances they apply
themselves more it appears
but uh with the energy
Memphis the teaching that we have added
methods of stimulation and with the two
group broad spectrum of approaches that
they have I think the medical students
today is ahead of the medical students
of yesterday the do you think medicine
is continuing to attract uh
the very best college graduate as
what a runtime we did have a problem I
would say about
10 5 10 years ago about the interview
was doing engineering or something
that's all rather than going to Medicine
we were brilliant because medicine was
too much punishment and uh with this
type of thing it could go and get off
from go from eight to five to working
with everyone by getting up at night and
Physician's Sons uh and daughters I
figured that was a better way to make a
living when they're going to Medicine
but I think that's beginning to change a
little bit now because we realized that
medicine is a very important calling and
as a matter of restoring individuals to
health is one of the greatest things
that individual can do for his lifetime
Cody how did you survive the times when
medical students were pretty much in the
vote I don't think uh one sees a great
deal of that uh right at the moment but
I understand that that was a good deal
of that going on
in the latter half of the six days and
particularly in schools like Mary yes it
just so happened by the nature of me
perhaps but I've been able to develop a
good disputer code with medical centers
through the years the first thing I give
them absolute freedom all the Liberty
wanted and criticize me asking any
questions they want and whenever they
have a problem I'm willing to listen to
it and that type of thing and as a
result I've had no problem they have
cooperated with everything I wanted to
do uh even to take the bids off was that
you don't care about it no honorable no
I don't be stupid no no the bills has
nothing to do with their brains I don't
care how long the bread's all on the
areas I do care about the brains and how
much time to put in their studies
okay now let's uh
to go back once again
you've been a physician now for 40 plus
years
you've lived through a time period when
there were no antibiotics
the last night you were talking about
the treatment of PID
with uh milk injected into the buttocks
Etc through the
Discovery and the use of the sulfport in
my eyes to the antibiotics to
you're a anesthesiologist
how do you feel about this tremendous
Panorama of things that you've seen a
car in in your lifetime
well the first thing is on for the good
it is a natural thing of progress
and we must realize we will go through
the mail and we can live through the
years but uh time means progress and
that is progress occurs we have to keep
up with progress that is one thing that
Physicians and others must do what we
learn when we finish medical school
would do us not much good today unless
we kept up every day we keep up we must
read our journals we must go to Medical
Society meetings and we must go to all
of them that we can go to and you'll be
sure to keep up with the latest things
because what we learn when we finish
medical school is almost obsolete today
and so it must be accepted that there
should be an increase in the amount of
things to which one is exposed but now
you see what how can you cram all out in
the four years or three years but what
we've done through the years is we've
dropped similar stuff we don't have
those lectures on typhoid fever anymore
because you don't have no time for the
fever we don't have much time on
tuberculosis
but you have all these new things
nutrition and a metabolic diseases and
that type of thing we must pay attention
to
this it seems to me to have changed very
significant in some other ways
because nowadays we have uh
what do you call them consumer consoles
yeah yeah yeah and uh we have lay people
coming in and uh CHP telling us what
we're going to do
the relationship between American
medicine and the Society of which we
apart is very very much different now
from what it was 40 years ago how do you
feel about that well I tell you that's
one of the hardest things for the
medical profession to accept I mean
those who are disturbed about that type
of thing
because medicine generally has just said
it's a matter of relationship between a
doctor and the patients no alignment
should come in between
But as time developers Society developed
not only America but throughout Europe
Asia everywhere we found out that the
consumer is beginning to have more to
say about his health care he has more to
say about
what type of care he gets when he gets
it and the rest of it every Justice well
to accept the fact that the consumer
going to have something to say about his
health care and go along with it
coming
if we could go back
a few years then you had to decide again
and you again at choosing a career
but in the present setting we just don't
choose to be a physician I would still
choose to be a physician still going to
surgery right still going to say there's
no question about it
okay why
well the first place I think one can get
a greater fulfillment from my point of
view
by doing medicine and we can't buy
anything that I can think of now the
medicine you can get a better
fulfillment than doing surgery than in
their branch of medicine and the
Fulfillment that one gets in his own
soul is important you didn't go into it
because you do go to you wouldn't do it
because you enjoyed doing what you do
right correct
not even for money because being ahead
of an apartment just being a school
teacher is not money because all the
fellows that I trained were not teaching
making money
what would you like for the future of
your profession
no I think that maybe
we should go back to a little broader
base of training of surgeons
alternative medical schools students
because the training now has almost gone
to specialize in the right eye and
that's too much I think we should go
back to a broader base because one could
do a better job with the eye if he knows
the basic Sciences if you know something
about some of the other disciplines and
so in some way I think we should be able
to give the individuals who run into a
particular specialist a broader base and
a wider Brave base of training
that doesn't conflict with our 28 month
deal I ask you about it well yes it does
in a way but how are you going to
reconcile those two things I don't know
but I do know that the time as chairman
and curriculum committee that the time
was used for
between the solution is not necessarily
that's what medical school does people
it doesn't really educate folk does it
no I know profession
no professor in the world can educate a
student a student must educate himself
the only thing the professor does is
guide him direct him stimulate him
that's why in our discussions with my
staff with the curriculum committee I
let them go ahead and prepare our
lecture for 10 hours for one hour
lecture and I agree with the students
with the same type of thing to make the
students go bigger out of various
journals and various textbooks and bring
it back to me and I just straighten them
out and those two groups of students the
one who do it themselves will learn four
more
what do you think is going to happen
about Healthcare delivery system
he's going to continue to grow but I
think he's going to go
about toward the involvement of a larger
number of people
we have health care delivery now but a
large percentage of the population of
America does not have good health care
actually we don't know how to level this
health care that's why we have such a
large research granted behind just for
the best method of delivering health
care but I think the biggest single
thing is the fact that it does not
involve enough people you know you see
I'm from university health insurance of
course that is one of the answers and
that way uh all the individuals can get
health care properly if we of course
you're going to have enough doctors
therefore we've got to go to the
so-called physician extenders and that
type of thing and when for the question
of uh of the government paying for
health care I'm for that I remember when
I was president of the national Medical
Association the American Medical
Association was fighting Medicare uh as
president of the national Medical
Association I insisted that we must
support uh Medicare because so many
blacks and some of the poor people could
not pay for medical care Medicare and uh
at that age and with the Medicare they
would be assured of a good training when
we met with uh President Kennedy in
those days uh we pointed out Grew From
the national Medical Association but we
were for the program 100
nowadays you know Provost for external
Affairs exactly what does that mean what
are you doing well I tell you Provost uh
I don't know what it is I haven't seen
anybody we didn't know so I just called
myself doing something but actually
theoretically when the president caught
himself promoted me to that it was an
academic appointment and what it means
is
uh we only have 225 future beats an hour
we started off with 65 students now
which is 112 students we have not
increased the bids and so my business is
to increase the bids the number of beds
in various places for the training of
medical students now uh it is on various
ways of course but after now we've
increased about almost 800 bids before
excluding the medical consumer with Cost
Containment because my hair is still a
matter of Cost Containment but Dr Walker
for me this has been a very interesting
session
and now that we've got to end we will
stop your punishment you may pull out
your cigar and light up thank you so
much
[Music]